Welcome to top five
of the DevBytes
series Making Apps Beautiful.
Thus far, we've built
an app that didn't
have a lot of love.
We modernized.
We performance tuned it.
But what we didn't do is make
it look exactly the same on
older versions of Android as
compared to newer versions.
So just to see exactly where
we were up to there, let's
look at our app on a Nexus
S running Android 2.3
Gingerbread.
So we're just starting it up.
And here it is, nice
and smooth.
But if we look at the title
bar, it's the old style.
There is no action bar here.
You wouldn't call this a very
modern-looking app, even
though it's running on an older
version of the platform.
And we can do better.
So let's switch back
to the slides.
And let's talk about backward
compatible action bars.
So there are a number of options
that you have when it
comes to backward compatible
action bars.
Two of the these are the
ActionBarCompat, which is part
of the Android SDK in the
Support Library, as well as
the ActionBarSherlock library,
which is a community effort
and much loved.
So after having integrated these
into our apps, let's see
what it'll look like on a Nexus
S. We're just going to
launch that version
of the app.
And there you have it.
You have a beautiful action bar
that is also themed along
with our brand.
So let's just now bring it side
by side with what we have
on a modern device.
And here we have the apps
running side by side on a
Nexus S, as well as the current
versions of Android.
Identical, which is fantastic.
So switching back
to the slides.
The action bar can be used
on newer versions of the
platform, as well as the older
versions of the platform with
these backward compatible
components.
And the nice thing about both
ActionBarCompat and
ActionBarSherlock is that
on newer versions of the
platform, they're basically thin
wrappers for the native
action bar.
It's not implementing everything
from scratch.
The other thing we should talk
about is the View Pager.
The View Pager allows us to
horizontally swipe across
pages to bring the previous or
the next page of content.
Let's see a demo of
that on our phone.
So we loaded the details
page here.
And you can see I can
swipe left or right.
And you'll notice here with
gestures, I don't need to
complete the gesture in
order for the next
content to come through.
While my finger is still on
the screen, I can see it.
So the View Pager is a great
way to page your content.
And it's also backward
compatible.
So switching back to the slide,
the View Pager is also
another really nice utility
class that you can include in
your apps through the Support
Library, and is backward
compatible to older versions
of Android.
Finally, I want to talk about
the Navigation Drawer.
The Navigation Drawer is a
patent that you've probably
seen in many apps.
But we have Android design
guidelines that describe
exactly how that Navigation
Drawer should
look like on Android.
Now you'll notice these screen
shots aren't from our
BaconReader app.
And the reason is is that we
don't believe in shoe horning
these UI patents into apps
where they may not fit.
So what we're going to look at
here is another sample app.
It's not the BaconReader app.
It's the sample demos that come
with the sample code for
the Navigation Drawer.
So let's look at that.
Let's switch to our phone.
We're going to load it up.
There's just a list
of planets.
But you'll see here on the top
left in the action bar, it's
not the traditional app icon.
It's not the angle bracket
pointing left.
It's these three horizontal
bars.
And when I tap it, these three
horizontal bars will actually
animate in and out to show you
whether the Navigation Drawer
has been expanded
or collapsed.
The other nice thing is, we
cannot only press the app
icon, we can actually swipe,
bezel swipe, from
the left edge in.
And also swipe that Navigation
Drawer out.
We can also dismiss it just
by tapping outside
the Navigation Drawer.
The other thing I want to
point out is some other
subtleties of the Navigation
Drawer.
And that is that when I slide
it in, you'll see that the
content kind of fades.
So we're making a concerted
effort to show that the
Navigation Drawer isn't
shifting the
content to the side.
It's overlaying on top.
And more importantly,
the action bar is
staying in its place.
The action bar itself does not
move as a Navigation Drawer
slides in and out.
So let's switch back
to the slides.
And the good news about all
these subtleties that we're
talking about for the Navigation
Drawer is that,
one, we've documented them on
the Android Design Guidelines
page for the Navigation
Drawer.
You'll see that on the bottom
right hand corner there.
But also, we've made this
Navigation Drawer available
for developers through
the Support Library.
Now if you want to learn a
little bit more about some of
the insights into why the
Navigation Drawer overlays on
top, and what the idea behind
the fading effect, or the
handover icon is, tune
into this Android
Design in Action video.
You can find it on the Android
Developers' YouTube page. .
The episode is called
Navigation Drawers.
And they actually interview
the engineers that built--
the engineers and designers--
that built
this Navigation Drawer.
So so far, we talked
a little bit about
this Support Library.
The great thing about the
Support Library is it's just
available as part of the
Android SDK Manager.
So you can just go ahead and
select it and add it.
Once you add that Support
Library to your app, you get
access to a whole range of
components that are backward
compatible.
So things like fragments.
And we have used fragments
in this app.
We saw our tablet layouts
and our phones layouts.
So in order to make this fully
backward compatible, we
actually used the support
fragments
from the Support Library.
Then there's new patents like
the View Pager and the
Navigation Drawer, which aren't
actually in the Android
framework yet but are available
in the Support Library.
And of course we've our
ActionBarCompat,
NotificationCombat, and others,
like Loaders as well.
So the Support Library is full
of useful utility classes for
developers.
And pretty much, there's no
reason why you shouldn't be
using it already.
So with that said, we've come to
the end of the Making Apps
Beautiful series.
On the left is where we started
on tablets and phones.
Not a very modern looking app.
Didn't look like the app
had had much love.
But through changes in layouts
by including backward
compatible components, as well
as through optimization
techniques, we've been able
to make it look beautiful,
perform great, and be fully
backwards compatible.
Thank you for joining us.